the CBI has been derailed by allegations
of a toxic culture and serious sexual
misconduct after an independent
investigation identified serious
failings even its president isn't sure
it can survive I'm deeply deeply sorry
for what those victims had to go through
it was absolutely horrendous the fox
women's reports helped us understand a
bit more about why some of these things
happened it also made a number of
recommendations 35 recommendations about
things that we could do to change a
process our culture the organization and
we have accepted those in full we've got
60 days to come back to the members with
a plan at egm in June were members
organizations for them to vote on that
plan and are we fit for the future in an
open letter to members Brian Bride
admitted the CBI had failed to filter
out culturally toxic people during the
hiring process had tried to find
resolution in sexual harassment cases
when we should have removed those
offenders from our business and allowed
that very small minority of Staff with
regressive and in some cases a attitudes
towards their female colleagues to feel
more assured in their behavior and more
confident of not being detected in
response the CBI will adopt a zero
tolerance approach to sexual harassment
and bullying Behavior compulsory
training covering bullying and
harassment prevention and recruiter
Chief people officer from outside the
organization and put in place a
permanent independent confidential
whistleblowing Channel
the allegations have seen scores of
Major companies cancel their membership
from John Lewis to Nat West and they'll
need convincing to return
I think for me I remain to be persuaded
that the toxic culture at the CBI that
clearly stretches back a number of years
and was unknown to the board this is
what Mr bride said in his letter I'm not
persuaded that I need to become a member
anytime soon
thank you well good morning everybody
welcome here today the cbi's move came
as the Prime Minister spoke directly to
200 company bosses at a government
conference in London proof of the need
for a dialogue with business even while
its biggest Lobby group is sidelined
business needs one voice to be able to
talk to the government the chancellor
said that today they need one single
voice to talk to we accept it today
that's not us but the work that we're
doing over the next 60 days is to
rebuild trust in this organization and
become that one voice for British
business
business needs a powerful voice in
public life the government is trying to
improve relations of the opposition are
hoping to establish their credentials
they both need someone to talk to that's
the CBI can address this crisis and win
back the confidence of its members it
won't be them
rain Newton Smith will start work as the
cbi's new director General this week she
has two months to restore faith in
business's biggest Advocate Paul Kelso
Sky News